Speaker 1: The indicted and since pardoned
Trump associate Roger Stone is predicting
that Donald Trump is going to be indicted,
that an indictment of Donald Trump is coming.
And this story didn't get much attention over
the Memorial Day weekend.
But Roger Stone appeared with conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones.
And, of course, he says it's a witch hunt.
Of course, he says it's nonsense.
Of course, he says these are going to be trumped
up political charges and it's trash.
But Roger Stone says an indictment of Donald
Trump is coming.
Take a look at this video.
Speaker 2: Globalists love symbolism, don't
they?
Well, I would be shocked if they did not come
forward with a fabricated indictment or bank
fraud or tax fraud against the former president
by Manhattan District Attorney Cyrus Vance
or an elected Democrat, the son of Cyrus Vance,
senior, the worst secretary of state in American
history, the man who botched the Iranian hostage
crisis under Jimmy Carter.
By the way, this is not exactly a non corrupt
politician himself.
Speaker 1: OK, so Roger Stone starts carrying
on there.
But the big point is Stone saying he'd be
shocked if there isn't some indictment of
Donald Trump.
We previously reported that the grand jury
is being convened.
They are looking at evidence.
They will decide on charges.
So this is real in that sense.
But Trump is lawyered up, presumably has top
lawyers already or almost ready to.
Represent him, if indeed this were to happen,
and I continue to believe that Donald Trump's
real level of risk is quite low of ending
up in prison, tiny, tiny, tiny, as I've said
before.
But what about the Trump children, not Baron
and Tiffany, but the ones involved in Trump's
businesses, Donald Trump Jr., Eric Trump,
Ivanka Trump, they are now being advised to
lawyer up personally because even though any
charges, if they ever come, will likely be
related to Trump organization activity, the
Trump Organization legal team really represents
the interests of the organization.
So here is Frank Thig Luzzi, former assistant
director for counterintelligence at the FBI,
explaining this to MSNBC.
Speaker 2: But the cool as we're talking about
witnesses, we might as well go ahead and talk
about kind of those big, big witnesses, which
is are we going to see this grand jury subpoena
or are we going to see subpoenas to testify
before this grand jury for people like Eric
Don Jr. and Ivanka?
And if so, are they going to plead the Fifth
Amendment against self incrimination?
Speaker 3: Well, you raise that.
I mean, I remember when The New York Times
big investigation into the Trump taxes came
out and all that liability that he had.
And you were part of our coverage about the
national security implications of that.
Right, that he was in so much debt.
If The New York Times learned that certainly
foreign government could have.
But one of the one of the line items for big
transfers to Ivanka Trump, would you guess
that they all have lawyered up in terms of
criminal defense attorneys?
Speaker 2: I wrote a column about that, and
so we lawyered up.
Yeah, they they have had to have lawyered
up because they may have already made the
mistake of casually speaking to the organization's
attorneys and the organization's auditors
about what they knew and what their role was.
A big mistake if they had done that because
the organization doesn't represent them.
The organization's lawyers mission is to preserve
the organization, not the individual executives
and officers.
It becomes every man or woman for themselves.
And in this case, the men and the women happen
to be family.
Speaker 1: So this has every possibility of
escalating dramatically.
And one more thing from Roger Stone here to
get back to him, Roger Stone predicts that
the timing of these indictments will be around
when the so-called audit in Arizona wraps
up.
This was mixed between ranting about other
things, of course, the damn lone.
Speaker 2: Well, let's be let's be very clear,
in other words, as you said earlier, you showed
the man, I show you the crime, they're allowed
to root through this man's business record
of 40 years in which he built a real estate
empire, second to none coming for a crime.
They have no evidence of a crime.
They have no probable cause.
It is disgraceful.
But I do think it is going to happen.
And don't be surprised if the announcement
comes at the exact time that we learn the
truth about Maricopa County, Arizona.
Don't be surprised because I see that coming.
Speaker 1: So that ominous timing predicted
by Roger Stone.
Is this just nonsense or does Roger Stone
actually know something or is he just guessing?
After all, Roger Stone told me during our
interview that he would never be indicted
by the FBI and he was indicted by the FBI.
So maybe Roger Stone just isn't the guy to
listen to about this stuff.
Or maybe Roger Stone does know something.
But it's going to be a very interesting upcoming
six months and probably the right advice for
the adult Trump kids to lawyer up.
My guess is they probably
have already.